I'm a sculptor sculpture is my priority
but I also do filmmaking free collage
paintings I've got my own space program
and I do tea ceremony too got there
our first space program was in 2007 went
to the moon and then in 2012 we went to
Mars and now at YB CA we've got Europa
Europa is the icing moon of Jupiter it's
got six times the amount of water that
Earth does the other NASA is sending
probes there to land there in a dozen
years but we can't wait for those guys
we're going and we're going now I've
been building sculptures for the past
thirty years and although there is a
almost an intellectual jihad against
functionalism in art the idea of what is
it is a chair oh I can sit on it easy
what is it the sculpture I don't know
what that means it's a little more
threatening conceptually but I've always
been interested in utility because it
has it has meaning in our lives that we
can understand and teasing the edges of
that is been interesting the launch will
be conducted by Colonel Tom sacks will
also direct the mission in its entirety
the launch supervisor has indicated that
we're go for launch
one minute 7 seconds there's a
performative aspect to the sculptures
but we try not and use the words
performance but demonstration or live
demonstration
well my space program is about space but
it's also about our life here on earth
we're Americans so instead of respecting
the ethical guidelines of not
contaminating other worlds with earth
bacteria we bring the noise